et can't confirm pop lock and drop it  rapper Huey has died at the age of 32  according to a statement released by the  st. Louis County Police Department the  rapper whose real name is Lawrence  Franks jr. died Thursday after suffering  at least one apparent gunshot wound Huey  was taken to a local hospital and  pronounced dead shortly after his  arrival a second victim a 21 year old  mill was also hospitalized he's  currently being treated for  non-life-threatening injuries police say  that after further investigation the  shooting which took place in the front  yard of a single-family residence in  kinloch Missouri were related Huey was  best known for his 2006 debut single pop  lock and drop it  which peaked at number 6 on the  Billboard Hot 100 the track was the  first single off his debut album  notebook paper which featured  collaborations with artists like t-pain  Trey Songz and Lloyd Huey is survived by  his 13 year-old daughter